tsa is warning the American trucking
industry about the possibility of
terrorists using big rigs and buses as
weapons vehicle terror attacks in Europe
have killed and injured hundreds of
people in the past three years Jeff
Pegues is covering the concerns here in
the US Jeff good morning good morning
the warning was really a reminder of
what federal officials have been
concerned about for some time now
terrorist organizations have been
calling on followers to turn large
trucks or vehicles in general into
deadly weapons this truck attack carried
out on the streets of Nice France last
summer killing 86 people and injuring
over 400 is exactly what US officials
are trying to prevent in a six page
report sent to the trucking in bussing
industry the TSA issued new indicators
and countermeasures to help prevent
terrorists from using commercial
vehicles to inflict large-scale damage
among the suggestions report suspicious
rentals that coincide on dates of
outdoor gatherings and reinforce strong
vehicle security the ramming attacks
have increased in frequency twelve
people were killed in Berlin when a
truck slammed into an outdoor market in
December
additional units near in 19th in college
we have several pedestrians struck by a
vehicle and in this country eleven
people were injured after a man inspired
by Isis drove his car into a crowd at
Ohio State University according to the
Department of Homeland Security since
2014 terrorists have carried out 17
known vehicle ramming attacks around the
world resulting in 173 deaths and 667
injuries the TSA says terrorists will
likely continue to encourage these types
of vehicle attacks because the reality
is they are easy to plan and have the
potential to inflict a massive amount of
casualties Nora
alright Jeff thank you